ich finde es nicht richtig der
Bevölkerung zu erzählen dass dieser
Kompromiss kurzfristig dazu führt dass
die Turnhalle um die Ecke wieder frei
wird das erstens erstens wird wird
dieser
erstens wird dieser Kompromiss wenn er
denn kommt am Ende des Tages in drei
Jahren Wirkung haben und zweitens ist
völlig offen wie weit die rechts
Wirklichkeit jetzt an dieser Stelle dazu
führt dass die zunehmenden
Migrationsströme und fluchtströme in der
Welt nicht mehr nach Europa kommen da
habe ich ganz realpolitische Zweifel und
deswegen würde ich das die Bevölkerung
nicht widersprechen das ist nicht
versprechen das ist nicht eine Lüge
[Musik]